Focusing on relevance and agency can
transform your communication and connect
your meaning to your audiences. My name
is Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to Think
Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
Today I look forward to speaking with
Sinéad Bovell. Sinéad is a futurist and
the founder of [music] Way, a tech
education company that prepares
businesses and the next generation of
leaders for a future shaped by advanced
technologies.
She is an [music] 11-time United Nations
speaker and serves as an expert advisor
to the UN [music]
AI advisory body. Sinéad helps bridge
the gap between complex technological
advancements and everyday understanding.
Welcome Sinéad. Thank you so much for
joining me here in the Theorist Studios
in New York City. I'm excited for our
conversation.
>> Thank you so much for having me. It's
great to be here.
>> Should we get started?
>> Yes, let's dive right in.
>> Excellent. Uh, you've been called the AI
educator for the non-nerds because of
your ability to take complex information
and make it accessible. How do you do
that? Are there certain frameworks that
you rely on? How do you take complexity
and make it accessible to people?
>> Mhm. Yeah, and I was actually surprised
by by that that slogan myself when it
came out. But I'd say you have to meet
people where they are and within
formation that's actually relevant to
them. So when it comes to technology cuz
that's something that I communicate
about a lot,
uh, it can seem really overwhelming for
people because people inherently assume
if you don't have the technical skills
or the coding skills or whatever it is
of the technology you're speaking about,
you're probably disqualified from the
conversation. And [clears throat] that's
not true. So you have to show people
perhaps an example of something that
would have seemed quite radical
historically, a technology that they now
use today fluently. Uh, and then also
how is this technology or the thing
you're communicating culturally relevant
to somebody's life? When things are too
abstract and you don't bring it down,
it's hard for people to connect with it.
So, I always try to meet people where
they are. And then I think there's a lot
to say about the format. So, is somebody
finding you on a YouTube video or on
something that's 90 seconds or something
more formal to try to fit the medium
because that's usually where the
audience That's how the audience expects
some form of communication or some form
of style. So, I try to be cognizant of
those things. And then I say the final
thing
if you're not passionate about the thing
that you're delivering and you don't
genuinely think it's important for
people to know or you're not excited
about it or concerned about it, that
also comes through and how you try to
get somebody to understand something.
So, if it's not genuine and you are not
actually excited about it or don't
really feel like it's important, that
also shows. So, I the things that you
see me talk about publicly are the
things that I'm I genuinely care about,
I'm inspired by them, or I think that
they're important, too.
>> And your passion certainly comes out.
I've seen you present a number of times
and you clearly are passionate and
knowledgeable, which are critical. So, I
heard you talk about several things
there. One, you have to meet your
audience where they are, which means you
have to understand and appreciate their
level of knowledge on the topic. You
have to try to make it relevant to them.
They have to be able to see how it
works. You rely on comparisons and
analogies to connect. And then you also
think, and I think this is really smart
to think about the channel through which
they're accessing the information and
try to conform to those expectations.
So, if you're if you're meeting people
on a a quick reel or a YouTube short,
you can't go into too much detail, so
you have to prioritize. So, excellent.
And that advice I think holds true for
anybody communicating about anything
that's complex. Uh, you frequently note
that soft skills appreciate over time
while technical skills depreciate. As
artificial intelligence takes over more
of our lives,
how can we
better lean into those soft skills, and
how can leaders and managers put an
emphasis on that for the people that
work for them?
>> Yeah, and this is a tricky one, right?
Because we've spent the last 15 years
hearing a lot about the more technical
skills and how important they are. And
it's not that they're not important,
it's just that the half-life of the
average technical skill is now between
2.5 to 5 years.
>> Wow.
>> So, that just means if you are leaning
into technical skills, you're going to
have to expect to continue to upgrade
and change. So, when we think about the
soft skills, and I don't even know if
they're soft skills, because skills like
self-directed learning, adaptability,
judgment, these can can be more
challenging to learn.
>> quite hard.
>> You have more opportunities to do so.
You can exercise some of this just at
home or in the grocery store, but they
do appreciate over value because these
are the the skills that the tools that
we're working alongside can't yet
cultivate. So, when it comes to leaders,
first of all, you have to guide by
incentives, right? So, what type of work
are you incentivizing? And this is
something I actually do see in
organizations. So, maybe a KPI or an
OKR, or some sort of benchmark
doesn't yet account for the fact that
you want your employees to to
demonstrate a different type of skill.
So, you suddenly tell them
communication's really important here,
and there's no opportunity for that
employee to deliver their presentation
in a way that they can express
themselves in a different format aside
from just some sort of email or some
sort of attachment. So, you do want to
try to align the incentives with that
directive, if you can also demonstrate
it, and then also give people examples
to show what why that skill is relevant.
So, if we're trying to get people to
build judgment skills or build critical
thinking, where does that matter in
their workflow and how they get
evaluated? And again, that comes back to
to the incentive systems because what
people don't want to feel like they have
to do is add more on top of something
that they're not even getting evaluated
on. I think inspiring people in that
way, giving people examples, those are
the areas that I think are are
important. And then we also just have to
start talking more about the value of of
these softer skills or the non-technical
skills and how centered they are
today and going forward.
>> Absolutely. The the ability to take
these skills that are non-technical and
really learn them and apply them is
really important. And again, very astute
to make sure that it's all about helping
people understand the relevance of those
skills, giving them opportunities to
practice and incentives. It's another
thing to support it, encourage it, and I
heard you also say role model it so
people see it. And take the time to
discuss it. You know, so many people,
especially in the realm of
communication, just assume that people
know how to do it. We have to take the
time to acknowledge and reward that,
too. So, it's it's building not just the
mandate, but building the infrastructure
to support it. You have had amazing
opportunities to communicate in lots of
different situations. You're up in front
of Fortune 500 companies, the UN.
How do you instill your message around
ethical use of technology, the
importance of AI and foresight
at the same time avoid people getting
really nervous, afraid, and and just
hunkering down with the way the status
quo is? How how do you encourage people
to adapt towards the future
without scaring them?
>> Mhm.
So, I'd say there the blanket approach
because it does I do change depending if
I'm in front of a Fortune 500 leader or
someone who's evaluated on different
metrics or has different goals and
incentives.
But I'd say the the theme behind my I
don't even have a strategy, but I think
what suits fits well with me
is if you scare people too much,
if you disempower them, they do
unsubscribe from the very activities you
need them to lean into. So, you can only
take people so far with showing the fear
and the consequences, and you have to
trust that when you are communicating
something that is uncomfortable, um
something that is urgent, that people
can follow you, and you don't need to
take them off the cliff. That they can
see what the consequence is if we
continue to go down, let's say, the
status quo, um without taking them to a
point where it feels like there's no
return.
Then you have to show how clear somebody
does have agency that is listening. And
so, if I'm in a room, let's say, with
world leaders, and we're talking about a
technology that seems like it's moving
really quickly, and it seems so foreign
and out of our control, and and
unprecedented as a term we hear over and
over.
Have we done this before? Was there a
moment in history that the same people
in this room did something similar, as
as radical, as profound? And so, when
you take people to those moments, they
can start to see the path for
themselves.
When it comes to a Fortune 500 company,
again, I
constantly connect back to the
incentives. If you are being evaluated
by
the stock market,
that matters to you, right? And if it's
going to show up in your bottom line,
that's something that a
leader and of course they also care
about fairness and ethics. But if you
say, you know, you're you're also in
perhaps missing 40% of a market
by not addressing the bias in these
algorithms, that's really significant.
So, you can attach the fairness argument
in addition though, this is what also
matters to you in quarter one, in
quarter two, and you're leaving this on
the table. So, there's I think different
approaches depending on who's in the
room, but I'd say the the theme is not
to disempower people, because then you
do lose them, and that's the the the
wrong action that you're trying to to
inspire people to take.
>> A
>> A quick reminder to make sure you're
following our show in whatever app
you're listening to. This is the best
way to help our show grow and to make
sure you never miss an episode. And now
a word from our sponsors. Their support
helps us bring you this show free of
charge.
Over the course of my career, I've had
the privilege of working with some truly
amazing coaches. And I've also spent
years coaching others. And I can tell
you firsthand, coaching makes a real
difference. That's why I really
appreciate what strawberry.me is doing.
Strawberry.me makes coaching more
accessible, affordable, and global.
Whether you want to become a stronger
communicator, a more confident leader,
or simply more intentional in your
career, having the right coach in your
corner can make an enormous difference.
Visit strawberry.me/smart
and take 50% off of your first session.
And make sure you let them know Matt
sent you. And now, back to our
conversation. There's a lot there I want
to dig into.
It starts with really appreciating that
what you're talking about
can be perceived as scary and as
threatening.
And once you understand that, then I
think many of the techniques you
mentioned are really important. Making
sure people have a sense of agency,
connecting it to things that they might
have done in the past when they've been
challenged. Helping them to see the
incentives are in alignment. All of
those make a lot of sense. You've built
a massive digital platform to educate
youth on the future of technology. What
have you found to be the most effective
storytelling techniques to reach that
generation or or storytelling techniques
in general?
>> I mean, and this what I can come back to
what are the things that matter for that
audience. So, storytelling around
education, skills, jobs, choices that
they would be making in their day-to-day
life. I tend to have that through line
between, you know, whether it's Substack
or whether it's something that I'm doing
that's a 90-second video, again meeting
that audience where they are.
But also showing them the path to
the decisions that they're going to make
today.
Connecting the storyline to their
future, right? Cuz the the futures that
we're building today, we're actually
giving it to that generation. So, I
think showing them that that this is why
this is something that's important to
you, even though it may feel like you're
not in that decision-making room, by the
time you get there, these are the
decisions today that you're going to
inherit, and this is why you need to pay
attention, and this is how you can make
a change. And then also making things
fun and not always overly
intellectualized just for the sake of
it. Get to the point as well. People
have things to do. You're also competing
with a lot of other pieces of content or
or media streams. So, respecting
people's time, and I actually see it as
that. Not just
to communicating quickly because the the
medium says 90 seconds or less,
but if someone's going to stop and
listen to you and take that time,
respect the time that they're giving
you, right? Communicate the fact
clearly, say the important thing, and
strip away everything else,
and and deliver in a way that makes
sense to the audience that you're asking
to to lean in and listen.
>> That respect piece, I think, is really
important, especially when talking to
younger folks who might feel they're
left out or not respected in this. So,
taking the time to respect that you're
listening,
demonstrating or showing them how
getting involved now will help with
their futures and the decisions being
made now to understand those will help
you to determine that future that you
that you live in and hopefully
co-create.
>> I think there can be the temptation to
think, well, I'm speaking to a really
young audience. I have to change the
tone, and they're only going to
understand some things. And that's
actually not true. Sometimes, you know,
they also want to be spoken to like the
rest of the adults in the room, cuz the
message is just as serious for them, uh,
or they feel like, you know, this
matters for me too. So, you don't have
to
cut off half of the important message
because you think I'm too young to hear
it. If it's important for my future, I
qualify to listen to it. So, sometimes
my message is actually quite similar,
and so is the delivery.
>> Amen to that. Uh, we we don't have to
talk down to people who are younger or
who don't have the technical background,
etc.
Find ways to connect. Find ways to make
it relevant.
>> We'll be right back to finish our
conversation. But first, a quick word
from one of our sponsors. Their support
allows us to bring you this show free of
charge.
Think about the last time you walked
into a big meeting, presentation, or
podcast recording, and wished your key
points could just stay with you without
losing eye contact or your train of
thought. That's exactly what Even
Realities was built for. Even G2, our
productivity smart glasses, designed to
keep real-time support right in view.
With teleprompting, conversation
support, real-time translation, AI
assistance, and more. They help you stay
on top of work and daily life.
And unlike most smart glasses, they're
designed to look and feel like premium
eyewear, with no camera and a
lightweight design you can wear all day.
To learn more about Even G2, go to
evenrealities.com.
And for our listeners, use promo code
thinkfast at evenrealities.com
to get 10% off Even Ring One and or the
Even Clip when you add them to your Even
G2 order. And now, back to our
conversation.
>> I want to switch gears and talk a little
bit about you and your career. Uh,
you've made several career leaps. Uh,
you started in finance and management
consulting. You did a little modeling in
your career.
What advice do you have to someone who's
trying to rebrand themselves and
communicate the the new way they are in
the world?
>> It really comes down to the fundamentals
of business, right?
The thing that makes you different, that
is actually your competitive advantage.
So, sometimes we can feel like when
we're changing lanes to what would seem
on the outside
towards a path that seems like it is
nothing it doesn't connect to the thing
that you're doing or you're making
[snorts] a entirely right turn when
everybody else is going straight. That
actually puts you at a unique
intersection that nobody else operates
on. That is a superpower in and of
itself. Uh so, I think that is one area
that I try to tell people doesn't matter
how many zigs and zags in your in in
your career you want to make, there's a
way to connect those dots that make you
unique and that's what also can make you
stand out. And you also learn a lot
about the world and different markets
based on the different audiences and
worlds you interact with. It wasn't
until I left business and went into
fashion
that I was inspired to talk more about
business and more about technology and
more about strategy because I realized
who was being left out of that
conversation. So, sometimes it can
surprise you what you discover about
yourself and your skillset when you step
into the unexpected. And that's what I
have found consistently in my career.
And you know, it's the more I'm
in a position that seems like it's it's
entirely unrelated to the one before it,
the more the previous experience uh
comes into play and the more it becomes
the strength. Uh so, that's how I've
connected some of the dots in my career.
>> I really like this notion of step into
the unexpected, look for the
intersectionality and what that does to
make you unique.
How have you communicated that though? I
can understand the the items that you
would want to communicate as a result,
but how have you thought through how
best to communicate that? Cuz many
people listening, I think, haven't had
some pivots, maybe not as dramatic as
yours.
>> I think everybody can relate
to being passionate about something or
super curious about something
and making the decision not to pursue it
and perhaps regretting it.
So, for me, I chose
to take that risk and make the decision
to step into the unknown. And so, I
think that there's a through line that
we've all or we've all been at a point
in our life in some way that we faced a
trade-off or we faced a decision.
Uh and it seemed like one was a lot more
foreign and one was a lot more unknown
and we all dealt with it in different
ways. Uh so, for me, I think I
communicate you know, these were my
curiosities, these were my passions, and
I knew I had to follow that line. I knew
that I had to take that leap. Uh and
that was the risk that I was comfortable
and I was willing to take. And I think
also
you know, I had equipped myself with a
bit of a foundation so I could take a
leap.
Uh and so, that's something, but you
know, sometimes I'm also these are the
decisions that I made and as Steve Jobs
says, you know, the dots only connect
when you look back. And that's one of
those examples, I'd say.
>> I like how you immediately connected
this to something that other people are
doing. Lots of us have passions that we
we might regret. And and that's a that's
a great way to start. And it shows that
you're somebody who's passionate and
willing to to
investigate and explore them.
>> And we have varied multi-ed interests,
right? No one is just one thing.
>> Right.
>> We're coming out of this industrialized
economy where it feels like you are your
job title, but that's actually not true.
Most of us have many different interests
and and varied interests at that that
seem unrelated to other people, but not
to us. We are the through line in those
ideas.
>> We are the through line. I I like that.
Before we end, I like to ask three
questions. One I make up just for you
and the other two I've been asking for a
long time. Are you up for that?
>> do it.
>> I am very impressed with not only your
thinking but the way in which you
articulate your ideas. How did you learn
and how do you continue to learn to
communicate effectively? What do you do?
>> I am constantly doing it. So whether
that is making a social media video and
sometimes you are actually
moving through the knots of how do I
actually say this in 60 seconds? And to
continue to try to master that craft,
I'm on stages quite a bit discussing
some of these ideas, uh communicating
them passionately with friends and you
don't have to be a professional
communicator and get paid for it, but if
there are things that interest you, a
news story, geopolitics,
sharing those ideas with people can
start to force you to communicate them
in a way that that audience, even if
it's one person in the coffee shop, is
going to understand. I'd say that that's
one thing.
Uh the things I communicate are the
things I'm genuinely very passionate
about. So I think that really helps.
Um and I I
practice. I think that there's for some
people they can grab a mic and it's very
ad hoc. And sometimes I do that, but I
also have no problem with rehearsing
something that's really important to me
and getting it down pat in a way that I
feel comfortable with. Uh it doesn't
work for everyone, but for me, I like to
come prepared and that's something that
I tend to do.
>> So the preparation, the repetition, the
passion is what leads you to continue to
develop the skills. And that's a good
lesson for everybody.
>> Mhm.
>> Question number two, who is a
communicator that you admire and why?
>> Steve Jobs is someone who I I rewatch
his speeches.
>> Mhm.
>> I rewatch his announcements.
And I'm I'm noticing the through line is
people who who make
very intentional pauses. And whether
that's planned or whether that's because
they are genuinely thinking. I think
President Obama does it as well.
Uh and so those are the types of styles.
I don't think I communicate anything
like either of those two. But they are
they are voices that I could listen to
on repeat. And there's a rhythm and it
feels like there's a call to action even
if there isn't one in the actual
message. Uh the call to action to come
back and to listen and to learn and to
be inspired. So I'd say those are two
two voices that I could put on repeat.
>> The intentionality and the presence
>> Mhm.
>> are what I hear you talking about. The
ability to pause, the ability to make it
sound like there's there's action to be
done even if there isn't.
>> Mhm.
>> We've we've heard those names before for
for very similar reasons. Yes,
absolutely.
>> And can I ask you about the pause? So
what is it with the power of the pause?
Is it intentional or does it seem like
it's natural or should do you encourage
people to pause more?
>> What we know is when somebody pauses,
it allows the audience to reflect and
catch up.
So it does a service to the audience. It
certainly can help a speaker to collect
their thoughts and move forward.
And we know from research in status and
power that those who pause typically are
perceived as having higher status and
power
>> Interesting.
>> So one of the recommendations to
somebody who's wanting to bolster their
standing in a group might be to speak
more slowly, to pause a little longer
because we typically assume somebody in
a in a position of power and status
uh do that. The other thing that pausing
does is it allows you to regulate your
breathing. And a lot of the nervous tics
that we have, speaking too quickly,
having our voice change, saying lots of
filler words, is a result of breathing
too quickly. So pausing can be very
important not just for you, but for the
audience that you're speaking to. But it
has to be genuine. You can tell somebody
who's
>> Yes. Right.
>> putting in pauses when they speak. So uh
again through practice, repetition,
getting feedback as you mentioned, you
can find what works for you. Without
pausing, I'd like to ask you a final
question.
What are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe?
>> The topic has to has to matter to you or
be something that you feel called to
speak about. I'd say the second
What is the take-home message that you
want people to be leaving with? If there
was just one idea
and sometimes I even say that in my my
talks, if there was one thing that you
listened and I announced the thing.
And I would say
the third in effective communication
for me a sense of calmness.
Uh people can really feel if you feel
uncertain or if you feel somewhat
anxious. So, I try to be as calm as
possible. And that's what has worked for
me. So, I'd say being passionate about
the topics
the take-home message
and delivering it with a sense of being
comfortable with the things you're
saying. Not necessarily comfortable in
front of people or on live television,
but with the things that you're
delivering. I think that that helps.
>> Those listening in know I love
acronyms and alliteration. And so, if
you allow me, I'm going to take the
third thing you said and and reframe it
a little bit, but it's about topic,
something you're passionate about. It's
being clear on the takeaway. And it's
finding the tone that fits for you. So,
it's the three T's. So, thank you for
that. And thank you for this entire
conversation.
You've opened my mind and hopefully the
mind of those listening in to the power
of possibility but the responsibility we
have to think about how we bring others
along and how we can have a sense of
agency. And your focus on really helping
make things be relevant to people and
inspiring while being honest and direct
are really important. So, thank you so
much for your time.
>> Thanks for the thoughtful questions.
This has been a pleasure.
>> Thank you for joining us for another
episode of Think Fast, Talk Smart the
podcast. To hear more interesting and
insightful episodes like this one, be
sure to check out our back catalog of
episodes in your favorite player or at
faster smarter.io.
This episode was produced by Katherine
Reed, Ryan Campos, and me, Matt
Abrahams. Our music is from Floyd Wonder
with special thanks to Theory Studios in
[music] New York City and Podium Podcast
Company. Please find us on YouTube and
wherever you get your podcasts. Be sure
to subscribe and rate us. Also, follow
us on LinkedIn, TikTok, and Instagram.
And check out faster.smarter.io for deep
dive videos, English language learning
content, and our newsletter. Please
consider joining our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community at
faster.smarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, Matt's AI
coach, and book club opportunities.
Again, that's faster.smarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast,
Talk Smart learning community.